gotten a lot of support and just you
know I appreciate everything and I'm
happy to be going to work well she's not
going to work just yet that was Amy over
the weekend in NYC after news of her
secret relationship with Good Morning
America co-anchor TJ Holmes went public
now E.T can confirm the two have been
temporarily taken off the morning Show's
third hour as ABC execs figure out what
their next steps will be good afternoon
and welcome everybody to what you need
to know on this Monday Amy Robuck and TJ
Holmes have the day off yep that's
Stephanie Ramos and Geo Benitez filling
in for Amy and TJ on Monday's show I'm
Stephanie Ramos and I'm Gio Benitez we
are so glad you are here with us to
begin this brand new week here on gma3
and while the duration of Amy and TJ's
time off air is unclear A source tells
E.T that this is not a disciplinary
action it's just to let things calm down
as for the rest of the staff
ET Source says the relationship is all
anyone can talk about adding that they
have mixed emotions about it quote
everyone was wondering when the bosses
would step in and now that they have
it's a waiting game good afternoon
everybody Welcome to what you need to
know gma3 and it's Friday e Amy and TJ
reunited on GMA last week after the
Daily Mail published pics of them
packing on the PDA all over New York
who's looking forward to the weekend uh
me yeah yes eagle-eyed fans were quick
to notice that neither of them were
wearing their wedding rings and now our
sources the journalists both separated
from their spouses back in August Andrew
and I are in our second marriage we have
a blended family we have stepchildren
Ex-Wives ex-husbands Amy's married to
90s heartthrob Andrew shoe he played
Billy Campbell on Melrose Place
yeah I'm doing all right considering
everybody thinks I should be falling
apart and since 2010 TJ's been married
to Marilee fibik an attorney who's also
chief of staff at Jay-Z's Rock Nation
they share a daughter and TJ's also dad
to two other kids from a previous
relationship keeping the romance alive
in any relationship well maybe it's a
challenge these days just a little bit
sometimes our source notes that Amy and
Andrew sold their apartment back in
September and we're planning to announce
their split prior to the news of her
romance with TJ going public as for Amy
and TJ a source previously told ET that
the relationship has been going on in
secret for quite some time this is the
Platinum party at the palace thank you
so it's nice alliteration there adding
that they did their best to keep things
professional and private on set even
when The Vibes are fun and sometimes
flirty
[Music]
thank you